s'il est un sujet de discorde c'est bien
celui qui concerne le ramassage des
ordures ménagères de systèmes sont
actuellement en concurrence
la taxe d'enlèvement majoritaire dans la
région calculée selon un pourcentage sur
la taxe foncière redistribué aux
communes qui tient compte du type de
logement pavillon ou appartement et que
le propriétaire répercute sur le
locataire ensuite la redevance
incitative qui est basée elle sur le
principe que chaque foyer paix au
prorata de la quantité de déchets
rejetés et selon le nombre de personnes
résidant sur le lieu d'habitation
un système jugé plus écologique
puisqu'il incite à trier et à consommer
moins mais qui applique la mise en place
de puces permettant de détecter le
nombre d'enlèvements dans sept communes
du cher par exemple le syndicat
intercommunal a mis en place un forfait
de ramassage comprenant une levée de
poubelles par mois les autres étant
facturés en plus et c'est là où les
associations d'usagers trouve que cette
redevance incitative et socialement
injuste puisque les familles nombreuses
sont celles qui paient le plus jusqu'à 2
à 300 % par rapport à la taxe
d'enlèvement calculer l
selon les revenus